[Music]
you
all right good morning ladies gentlemen
the welcome to the inaugural symposium
of the pker Institute for learning
memory at MIT the future of the brain
I'm Susumu tonegawa director of the
piccola Institute for learning memory
today in the first of December and the
first is appropriate for such a day like
today this celebration and you know a
former inauguration of the peak of our
Institute for learning memory in the
first page of a new chapter of the
future of the brain research this today
marks a first milestone of the in the
history of the piccola Institute because
this is the first time the all the
members of the peak of our Institute and
the laboratories have been assembled
under one roof and even it magnificent
roof we have
[Applause]
the person I'm about to introduce has
many firsts in her life and in her
accomplishments
too many to mention but - in my view -
stands out we add particularly
significant today and this person is the
first riped scientist to read MIT and
this person is also the first woman to
hold this post of MIT president and I'm
of course speaking about a pseudonym hot
doctor to the Hockfield who is the 16th
president of Massachusetts Institute of
Technology dr. Hockfield is noted
neuroscientist in her own right but with
her at its helm MIT is poised to have
many first in coming years integrating
life sciences with engineering and the
technology which are inhibitory we
foster the negativity foster the promise
of many firsts many discoveries and this
data the discoveries which were surely
and dramatically enrich and improve the
world we live in
so please welcome our president Sudha
Hockfield
morning everyone thank you so much for
the introduction I just say I love this
building it's an enormous privilege and
it really it's a great joy to join all
of you this morning for the formal
inauguration of the Pocari Institute for
learning and memory I can't imagine a
better way to inaugurate this new home
and the first important new chapter than
the distinguished symposium this morning
on the future of the brain and what a
spectacular symposium have promises to
be it's a roster of who's who in the
global neuroscience community we all
know about Susumu persuasive abilities
and tenacious persistence you can
imagine how much he had to exercise
those skills in assembling the stellar
group that will be with us today we have
pioneers in brain research the people I
consider to be the real thought leaders
in our field who will help us celebrate
the opening of this marvelous Institute
and we have a lot today to celebrate we
have a new place we have a great vision
we have a remarkable community and this
all has been made possible through an
extraordinary commitment by visionary
donors first a new place thanks to our
architects Charles curry associates and
goodI Clancy and associates thank you so
much for providing this
state-of-the-art space for the difficult
technical work of doing cutting-edge
neuroscience as well as together with
compelling community space that
catalyzes conversation and collaboration
it is a profoundly successful
architectural or architectural
phenomenon and we really thank you
second a great vision the vision for the
pick our is captured magnificently by
the title of today's symposium the
future of the brain the title is not the
future of brain research the future of
crane research would convey only what we
will do not the consequences of what
we'll do the consequence of the work
that will be done at the pick our
Institute for learning and memory will I
believe change the future of the brain
itself let me explain a little bit
through the pic our foundation Barbara
and Jeffery pick our support many
important programs but their deepest
passion has been for their programs in
education and medical research it's
their vision and it's a vision that's
shared with the MIT pick our scientists
that here research that leads to a
deeper understanding of learning and
memory will translate into improvements
and how we learn and remember those
improvements one day will amplify the
potential of Education and will also
reduce disease and age-related memory
loss simply said neuroscience research
at the pick our Institute will improve
human lives by improving the human brain
we enjoy a remarkable community here the
excellence the pick our Institute today
reflects the dynamism the drive and the
insight of Susumu tonegawa Susumu is not
just a brilliant researcher but also has
proved to be a superb institution
builder and a great talent spotter he's
assembled a cadre of scientists that
week after week in paper after paper
successfully tackles some of the most
interesting and pressing problems in
neuroscience today the incredible pick
our team is joined in this match
sniff assent building by a group of
extraordinary colleagues in the McGovern
Institute for brain research and the
department of brain and cognitive
sciences together more than 40 faculty
and I cannot imagine that anyone would
fail to see that this is one of the very
best communities of neuro scientists in
the world the larger environment of the
pick our amplifies its power by any
measure this intersection of Vassar and
Main streets has to be one of the very
most exciting and promising places for
one of the most compelling intellectual
domains of today which is taking form at
the convergence of the life sciences and
engineering physically present right
here in an area that I often call the
Great Circle is an astounding array of
activities at this convergence of course
in this building we have neuroscience
across the street in our new ray and
Maria Stata Center it houses our
departments of Electrical Engineering
computer science and also our Department
of linguistics and philosophy just
behind that is a building that houses
our division of biological engineering
next to that a building that holds our
Department of Chemical Engineering right
next to that is the department of
biology next to that our Center for
cancer research across the street just
diagonal from here is a new building
that's almost finished for the Broad
Institute that will take the power of
the human genome and turn it into new
ways of discovering diseases causes for
diseases and their cures next to the
broad is the Whitehead Institute for
biomedical research which has been a
fount of insights in molecular genetics
for decades this is a great circle that
brings together engineers and scientists
students and postdocs to create the new
world at this new intersection of course
can't neglect to mention our neighbors
the almost 150 pharmaceutical biotech
medical device companies that are within
walking distance of our campus and our
neighbors in the other direction across
the bridge the Massachusetts General
Hospital and three other of the leading
academic hospitals in the nation this is
a powerful combination
this is a powerful place it will in many
ways amplify the impact of the research
that's done in the pic tower now most
importantly today we celebrate visionary
donors the scientific power and
accomplishment of the pic our scientists
reflects the commitment of Barbara and
Jeffry Picower
their generous gift established a
permanent endowment to support pick our
Institute faculty and the research as
well as the construction of our
magnificent new facilities the
unrestricted funding that they have
provided sets these brilliant scientists
free now limited only by their
imagination and their intellectual
tenacity it is a great and a long
reaching gift thank you very much
in addition to the generosity the pic
hours the work of the Institute has been
catalyzed and has been supported by
other wonderful supporting organizations
the Sherman Fairchild finds foundation
really catalyzed these new neuroscience
activities at MIT the Rican brain
Science Institute has contributed
importantly to our work the NIH and the
HHMI has also provided important support
and we thank them all for the important
funding for this endeavor in the past
and the years ahead today we have
technologies available to us that were
simply unimaginable only a few years ago
and some of the best minds in the world
are turning to the study of the brain so
I am profoundly optimistic about the
future of brain science my own belief is
the work that will be done here at the
pick our Institute will go a very long
way toward alleviating the crippling
diseases of the brain toward enhancing
education and improving the quality of
our lives in closing let me just say
again how inspired I am by the pick our
Institute here at MIT I believe I speak
for all of us today when I thank again
Barbara and Jeffrey pick our the pick
our has other supporters Susumu tonegawa
and his incredible colleagues for giving
us a reason to expect revolutionary
results from the pick our Institute in
the years ahead
welcome to MIT welcome to the symposium
and please I hope you all enjoyed the
day thank you
welcome my name is Ira Flatow I host
science friday at NPR every friday hope
a few of you listen to us thank you
thank you I'd also like to thank all of
you for coming today and I'll just say
add my two cents to the beauty of this
building and I like how they built the
skyboxes up there you notice of people
up there and some Bob Uecker seats also
I think and we'll need you later cuz
we're gonna we're gonna be talking with
the Nobel Prize winning panelists we
have today let me let me tell you a bit
about what's gonna happen this morning
we're gonna have a panel discussion I'll
sort of be your tour guide for the for
the day today we have an unprecedented
assemblage of Nobel Prize winners who
were as it Sullivan used to say right
here on our stage will be assembled and
each one of them will present to make a
short presentation about where they see
brain research going they'll be sort of
limited to amount to the amount of time
they can talk but you know trying to get
scientists to do anything is like
herding cats so we'll see how well that
works out so each one of them is going
to come up and make a short presentation
we'll have a break around 10:25 and then
we'll come back we'll finish the
presentations and then we'll have
questions and odd questions from the
audience and I'm hoping everybody if
you're up there you can shout out a
question through down here we'll have a
couple of microphones to pass around so
that you can ask the questions first up
of our first Nobel Prize winners as
you've already met dr. tonegawa he is
the winner of the 1987 Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine he's also the
director of the peak-hour Institute so
let's please welcome back dr. Tarr
nagawa
[Applause]
okay that task assigned to me and my
Pharaoh Nobel laureates this morning the
IRA told you is to predict about the
future brain and the brain research and
this is a very difficult things to do
the French dramatist using UNESCO said
we can only predict things after they
have happened so nevertheless I urge my
fellow speakers to venture into this
difficult task I myself had a good
excuse to spend the sum of actually most
of my time doing preparing another task
that is to introduce you the pick our
Institute and it's so I will give you a
short account of what a biased account
of what I think will happen in the brain
and brain research in the future at the
end of my talk but let me first give you
a brief account of the mission of the
peak of our Institute and its work so
peak our Institute is in the department
of neuroscience research center at MIT
and it intellectual focus indicated here
into deciphering molecular cellular
network and the brain systems mechanism
for learning and memory and associated
cognitive phenomena such as attention
emotion consciousness etc in health and
the disease now here the brief history
of the peak of our Institute it started
with with a grant from the Chairman
samuel.rachael foundation at a small
Center for running a memory in 1994 and
a three years later she REM was expanded
on the collaboration with
bring Science Institute of Japan and
then the serum would here further
expanded in 2001 and renamed the Deepika
a center for running a memory with a
large and the generous gift from the
pickerel Foundation established by
Barbara under Jeffrey Piqua
in the 2003 we had a groundbreaking of
the brain cognitive science project
building this building here the home of
the homes for the Pico Vasanta McCubbin
Institute and bling and human team
science department this year the area
this peak of our Institute would be
named as a peak of a Center was renamed
at the peak our Institute for learning
memory the peak of a building was being
inaugurated now we put this learning and
memory at the part of the name of the
Institute so why do we study memory
well because memory is a mental group in
the central to our mind now for you in
daily conversation memory might be misty
recollection of a past times or a
desperate effort to find the lost keys
but actually memory is much more than
that
it is a mental grew to bind your life's
experiences so imagine a life without
without memory capability the life like
that will be a life in dissolution life
with no connection to your past present
and the future and it will be the life
with no ties to people or to events
occurring around you most tragically the
life without memory means you don't have
sense of yourself
and therefore often the alzheimer
patient in advanced stage will ask you
this question
would you please remind me and
Who I am so for some of you probably it
you will agree that memory and other
cognitive function is based on the
function of the brain but some of you
might be a little bit surprised if I
tell you that this brain actually is a
machine and it is a machine with the
machine evolutionarily assembled on this
planet in the most complex machine this
diagram shows how the information flow
in this machine so the information is
extracted from experiences and
environment through the sensory system
shown here and some of the information
will be processed and stored in part of
the brain such as neocortex and the
other part right hippocampus and the
basal ganglia this stored information
subsequently will be compared and
integrated with the information which is
arriving to them to the machine to the
person to the animal moment moment
online information and then the command
signal will be generated and that will
be command will be executed through the
motor system now the one of the hallmark
of the brain particularly the human
brain is an enormous complexity and
multi-layer organization so at the
bottom you start with molecules DNA
proteins and other variety of molecules
with low molecular weight which generate
compose very specialized area areas of a
single cell such an synapse dendrite
axons soma and the song and those of
different parts of the cell compose a
single independent neuron which showed a
particular function and these single
neurons interact each other through
synapses to form so called brain and
Savonarola ensembles and indeed neuron
ensembles with different kind will
interact each other to form what is
called the brains functional brain
systems such as hippocampus and then a
different brain system interact such a
coated amygdala and hippocampus to
generate a function of the whole brain
and that is the basis of the cognition
and behavior herbalife whole life
animals such as Drosophila Mouse monkey
and my postdoc Arvind so you can imagine
from this that if you really want to
understand the mechanism underlying
cognition like memory you need you need
to identify the processes and events
occurring at all of these different
level of complexity that and then
further to identify cause effect
relationship of the events occurring at
the different level of complexity and
then in order to do that one need
variety of different experimental
technology designed to detect these
processes event at a different level so
at peak our Institute we use a variety
of different technologies we use
molecular biological cell biological
techniques reg shown here and also oops
so and then we reuse in vertebrae and
but great Jeanette genetics we reuse
electrophysiology of live cells at the
brain slices or culture the neurons and
we reuse also in vivo recording so
called in bebo recording of ripe animals
by implanting electrode into the
experimental animals and then we also
used very high-tech imaging technology
such as composure microscopy multiphoton
microscopy and so on and then we also
used a non-invasive imaging technology
like functional MRI and the finally at
the highest level with we also subject
animal to the variety of behavioral
studies now to cherry out all these
analyses it a daunting task that is
beyond expertise of one person or one
laboratory so at the peak of our
Institute strategy is to assemble people
trained in a different field different
expect with the different expertise but
they are all interested in this large
intellectual theme that is learning a
memory and brain plasticity so here is
the picture of the current pickle
Institute faculty bugbear it in a DB how
Rose rose
yes yes yes Inori Hayashi myself began
she'll Midwesterner lumira through
written and we can conserve the great
thing about the pickle Institute faculty
as I said it still is very complementary
and there are a lot of collaboration
going on among different laboratory at
the same time keeping the identity of
each laboratory the another feature of
this faculty is that all of these
faculty relatively young
study and forties
except on this guy
we have also two faculty members coming
next year in in 206 one in the leaf
which I currently at Harvard Medical
School and she will give you a short
presentation this afternoon see the
expert in basic mechanism of neuronal
migration as well as the cold at the
mechanism for underlying Alzheimer's
disease Andrew from short is another
person who would expect to come next
year and he currently the professor at
Cambridge University his expertise is
reward signal and a reward prediction
signal and learning now I have this task
of trying to give you a glimpse of the
some of the recent research
accomplishment from an epoch our
Institute but of course I cannot do it
justice on this subject because my time
is very limited so I hope my colleagues
will forgive me that the fact that I
picked just a few of them and even so I
could spend only two or three minutes
for each lab and try to explain to you
what they are interested in and what
they have done recently the first in the
Morgan Chandra
Morgan chain is a great molecular
neurobiologist and biochemist and he has
been won at least one of the major goal
of his laboratory is to decipher the
molecular architecture of this very
important unit called neuronal synapses
indicated in here
so they so his research will address
just right in order to build this
magnificent magnificent suspension
bridge or motor engine you have to
identify the components and then you
have to know how the
interact each other to form to form this
wonderful product and this is what he
they want to do we're four synapses and
so what is the molecular structure of
underlying components and how do they
interact together to allow neuro
neuronal communication that what is
called synaptic transmission and the
synaptic plasticity so here is the
electron micrographic picture of our
synapse which comes with this round
structure which I hope you can see which
is a pre synaptic vesicles containing a
neurotransmitter in this case glutamate
and then also in the lower part comes
with these glutamate receptors indicated
by this blue over science and the data
one being NMDA receptor and the writer
one AMPA receptors the match has been
known about the conceptually about these
receptors but the detailed structure of
them has been poorly known and change
rapidly have recently succeeded in the
visualizing AMPA receptors at very high
resolution at high resolution using
electron microscopic technology and
interestingly they found two forms two
forms of AMPA receptor it's called one
is called type 1 the other is type tool
and they have shown that the transition
from type 1 conformation to type 2
conformation correlated well with
opening in the receptor channel which
happens when the glutamate bind to these
receptor at the synapse this is a very
important fundamental discoveries which
had a lot of implications for future
drug discovery now my laboratory is
interested in
understanding the mechanism underlying
memory but using rodent of the the
experimental animal and we want to do a
studying this at both molecular and
circuit rebels earlier study had shown
that both in human on this left and and
also in the animals the part of the
brain called the hippocampus played a
crucial role in the most familiar form
of memory called exotic memory memory of
events memory of episodes however little
has been known about how the each sub
region of the hippocampus such as
dentate gyrus GST and the ca1 and in a
circuit connecting them will play a
specific law in a specific aspect of
episodic memory and our goal is to to
understand though the function of
different part of the hippocampal sub
region and the circuit and our strategy
main strategy is to use genetic
engineering and produce mutant mouse
strains in which a gene encoding a
specific receptor in this case NMDA
receptor that I referred to when we
talked about Morgan's work is gene is
deleted from the genome it's not the
problem
an MD receptor is not a functional
anymore but only in a particular part of
the hippocampus everywhere else the gene
is normal and then you subject this
animal to the behavioral studies and
find out what kind of a deficit today
show now it turns out I can't tell you
all the detail but if we're not artists
but one gene one adversary thousand gene
in specifically in the ca1
circuitry in the hippocampus then these
are maja severe problem and acquiring
memory but even after repeated repeated
practice but if you knock out the same
gene if you damage same gene in in this
in this area for the ca3 then the
determine totally normal in acquiring
memory however they exhibit
severe problem in the coding memory and
the other you know they recorded an
important and acquiring memory
information because if you don't record
it it can reuse the stored information
so now they have they show a specific
deficit during a record process they
can't recall in the normal way so what
do I mean by normal recording process in
order to explain that to you I want to
ask you a simple question did you have a
good dinner last night and many of you
probably did have a good dinner and you
are as I speak
you are recollecting you were
remembering the dinner you had yesterday
and the detail of that with whom where
and what you ate and the song in other
words you need only a fraction of
relevant information to record a rich
content of event you know in Etobicoke
record the memory this process is called
pattern completion and you can see it
appear but the pattern completion now it
turned out that if you knock out the
single protein in ca3 circuitry in
hippocampus then you can acquire a
memory but it can't recall the memory
with the limited huge it turns out this
is the capacity we normally have but it
is very sensitive to aging so they are
we get older come to my age we have
often problem in recalling the past
event with a very limited cure
everything get to the at the tip of the
tongue although that doesn't mean that
the memory it's gone it's there but you
need more choose to recall it and it's
the same thing in our er time a patient
they exhibit this this phenotype this
the symptom now if we look at the same
gene now in a dented jar this is go the
dentate gyrus area and then these animal
also have no problem
memory in January however they have a
different kind of deficit they have a
problem in distinguishing similar events
making distinct memory for two similar
events for instance if you translate it
to human if you park the car yesterday
in one of these laws and in this morning
park another place and in this afternoon
when you go there and in a large parking
lot you'll have a problem finding your
car unless your activity in a dangerous
if it is normal so that's the kind of
thing we do in our lab and now I want to
shift to Matt Wilson drag but Wilson
grab also interested in general used
rodent at the experimental animal and
study the hippocampus and some other
area of the brain but they study this at
neuronal ensemble and brain system
rewards we have a lot of collaboration
with them so they are also involved in
the molecular studies but their original
expertise come from this great
technology that he invented several
years ago that is while animal is
exploring a space like that surrounding
a choose and aqua and remembering the
feature of this space which will
generate what is called spatial memory
memory of particular space environment
as animal do that math technology allows
the monitoring of the change of the
activity of a bunch of a neuron pointed
in the hippocampus at animal former
memory and this can be analyzed in such
a way that you can detect what is called
representation of the behavior memory at
the level of activity of neuronal
ensembles and using this technology for
instance this is an example of ten cells
here from top to bottom this is the time
and when you see the color here that
means that that particular neuron this
is
you know while you're on paying here
going horizontally when you see this
color that means that you don't inspire
you are very active so animal is
exploring awake awake and exploring the
circular track and you can see that ten
neurons
fires at a very specific pattern like
this now if we put the animal human
iterator into a into a secluded area
where they can take to take a rest and
forestry and as during this REM sleep
they probably see dreams and we do an
amazing thing is without any input from
environment totally separated segregated
from environment the same set of neurons
fire in a pattern which is very similar
similar to the pattern that they fired
during awake exploration that means
there is a replay of activity internally
in the brain during the REM sleep and
since it is known that the replay will
help to fortified the synapses involved
in that neural ensemble Matt and his
colleagues proposed this is a mechanism
to stabilize memory to consolidate a
memory and so the message to the
students we are going to take a final
the song is that even if you want to
cram try to sleep the last three or four
hours and have a dream before you go to
their class all right now I want to
shift to a Macbeth Macbeth lab is a
major interest is change of the cerebral
cerebral cortex
particularly the visual cortex by a
sensory experience during development
Aria Marx made a great discovery on the
mechanism underlying snap tick
strengthening and where are the
weakening
they have shown that one form of this
synapse weakening due to the sensory
sensory stimulus called long-term
depression Ltd actually plays a crucial
or at least impact for that the
Rotarians effects of sensory deprivation
such as the visual deprivation during
the brain development now this is a very
basic study basic research but you never
know what basic research lead so recent
study has shown study in Europe have
shown that utd mechanism this weakening
of synapse leading to a discovery of
molecular mechanism for fragile X mental
retardation which is the the best known
invertible mental retardation and also
known cause of autism and amazingly they
are reason to study as suggesting that
this malfunction can be correctable by
drugs and Mark is marshalling the
resources to put it into the clinical
trial he hopes he can do that within a
year or two and finally I want to talk
about our mirrored work who mirror being
the Associate Director of the peak of
our Institute
so our works also uses the electro
physiological technique applied to live
animals but he uses primate monkeys
rather than rat and the monkey has a
certain advantage and experimental
animal because they are closer to us
they have a more sophisticated cognitive
function such as decision making some
other some other may be consciousness
and the zone so this is only one with
the many many accomplishment they are
mirror made during the past several
years but what they are studying
recently
in how we we have monkeys and we know
and follow rules what is called the
rosemary road running with a rate of
traffic right you don't cross a road
green you can go that route running okay
now the dogma in the field has been that
the evolutionarily more advanced area of
the brain called the prefrontal cortex
it's the one with nuns rule first and
then as you learn this and repeat this
then the more primitive part with the
brain called the basal ganglia shown on
this side that inside the brain takes
these familiar rules and the form
automatic habit you don't have to think
about when you cross the road here you
don't have to think about red oh today
oh yes I can go no you almost thought
you do that automatically so that's the
way the rules ruling in the usually
occurs but the recent study has
challenged this the dogma in the field
they have shown that the basal ganglia
runs rule faster than the prefrontal
cortex but this is the studying activity
following the activity of the neurons in
these two area of the brain if you also
followed the rule running by behavioral
experiment they have shown that actually
monkeys behavior follow the slower
prefrontal cortex so the primitive basal
ganglia may start running the rules
first
but the prefrontal cortex the brains
so-called executive branch of the brain
and the final arbiter of behavior
monitors the basal ganglia and more
slowly but more judiciously arrive at
the correct answer pretty correct
behavior so that's all time I have and
hopefully you allow me to use another
three minutes to speculate about the
future and so I have once right and in
here here it is Oh what happened here
okay so as I said future is difficult to
predict but I believe that in all of
these what I have talked about is
carried out using animal models but I
know that we some some work is going on
in throughout the world even in MIT to
understand try to understand how human
acquire memory and the song but in the
currently the major technology which is
used to study human brain is a MRI
magnetic resonance imaging and some
other technology which is called a
non-invasive technology these
technologies are very useful it's
generating given us a lot of information
but the people who are aware that there
is a limitation in this technology in
terms of temporal and spatial
resolutions so if we really want to
understand the mechanism brain mechanism
underlying human cognition in the future
we need entirely new technology which is
based on totally new principle which we
hope will be able to analyze what is
going on in the brain even at sub micron
level we did a level of the size of the
single synapses now where does it come
from what kind of idea is there I have
no idea and I don't think people have
idea either
but I would hope that the place like MIT
is the ideal place to promote and
explore this direction because we have
such a fantastic Department of
Engineering and
Department of Physics and the song we
should have which is promote the
interaction between neuroscientists and
engineer and the physicists of course we
have to continue to try to find a way to
develop a new diagnostic in the synaptic
method for psychiatric and neurological
diseases
amah in addition to the traditional
method of finding drugs by drug
screening as you know that for some of
these diseases the neural particularly
for neural degenerative diseases this
stem cell research is going to become a
very important and we can discuss this
the implication and promise of this
technology when we have a discussion
later and I would also like to point out
that although this is not in number
three this is not real syrupy for brain
diseases but the development of computer
brain interface so-called neuronal
prosthetic is very important because
this is the technology which will not
cure the patient but will improve the
quality of life of patients sometimes
very prolong the period more than thing
is like for instance Parkinson disease
there have been this technology being
applied and the patient's the patient
can live by themselves and I think the
place like MIT also should promote the
technology like in this in this field
and the four and five or more
philosophical things and I would like to
take that the neuroscience I will take
this position neuroscience is the first
natural science the branch of natural
science which other promise to integrate
natural science with humanity and social
sciences because after all what we do
what people study in humanities social
study I worried what in turn diffraction
the world is happening
the brain and also also including
engineering and of course in order to do
all this there will be a serious issue
of new the establishment of new ethical
guidelines which we can also talk about
later so I will stop it here and if I
took more time than assigned to me
I apologize thank you very much
[Applause]
I hope you were taking notes on this cuz
you will be tested later there is so
much to talk about later when we have
our general discussion after the break
I'm hoping you'll always questions about
some of the things that we're hearing
about from the speakers this morning our
next speaker is a sydney brenner dr.
brenner is a distinguished professor
researchers professor at the soft
Institute is one of the past centuries
leading pioneers in genetics and
molecular biology most least recently
dr. Brenner has been a studying
vertebrate to gene and genome evolution
and his work in this area has resulted
in new ways of analyzing gene sequences
which has developed a new understanding
of the evolution of vertebrates I'm sure
you're familiar with his with his work
and his discoveries among them being dr.
Brenner established the existence of
messenger RNA he demonstrated how the
order of amino acids and proteins is
determined he also conducted the
pioneering work in the round worm which
has been used as a model organism and
now widely used to study genetics his
research has garnered insight into aging
nerve cell function controlled cell
death apoptosis
he's also the 2002 Nobel Prize winner in
Physiology or medicine there's so much
to talk about law here with dr. Brenner
has chosen to speak about today dr.
Sydney Brenner
[Applause]
well thank you for the opportunity to
talk about the future in fact I should
be sitting down now because my time is
up but I'll speed up what I have to say
so that I don't poach too much on
Richard Axl's time I think it's very
hard to predict the future because I
think the future will be what we make it
if we know we're going to make it then
of course we'll predict it so let's see
what we want to make of the future we
talked about the future of the brain my
own brain has very little future but I
think the future of research into the
brain is going to be extremely important
and the first thing I just like to
emphasize something that Susumu said
which is that we have become released
from biological evolution the moment
primitive man gained memory learned how
to use tools we entered a new phase of
Cultural Revolution though as we didn't
have to wait millenia to gain mutations
that would give us a furry skin to
protect us from the cold we simply went
out and killed the bear and wore his
skin so when you think about it we are
all the products of the brain and as I
think I've often said quoting a very
well-known scientists called Woody Allen
that we have achieved more were the
second most important organ
in the mail body then was the first dog
so the important thing to grasp is that
it is also very important from this that
we are the products of our brains and
that all of our letter evolution since
last hundred thousand years perhaps
certainly the last twenty five thousand
has been the product of our brains but I
want to just talk a little bit more
rather on this rather broad area on
something which is a little detailed and
I'm sorry but I'll have to mention the
three letter word that DNA there are
enormous ly challenging questions left
of a great intellectual challenge and
they are to try to gain understanding in
what we've been doing for many years now
which is how to come how to gain an
understanding of how this internal
description within ourselves that is
written in the DNA language of our genes
gets transformed into fully functioning
organisms and I think that connection
between genotype and phenotype
especially for complex animals will
remain the most challenging problem in
biology and I don't think we can avoid
it because you realize that we can only
ask three questions in in the life
sciences we ask questions which is how
does it work which is questions of
function or physiology we ask questions
about how does it get
built just questions of development
construction and then the fundamental
question of all which is how did it get
that way how did we actually by changing
these letters in the DNA make things as
complex as ourselves and so different
from everything else and everything is
unique in that sense I've often said
that I only have one wish for the future
which is to be allowed to come back
wherever I am in 2050 3 on the hundredth
anniversary of the discovery of the
double DNA helix just for one day just
to see what has happened what the world
is like what science is like and if
they're listening somewhere I just
repeat the plea on this auspicious
occasion I think we are being compelled
biological sciences are being compelled
if not to act in that direction but
certainly to pay lip service to the
practical applications of our work that
is fine and I agree with that but we
should not let if I can put it crudely
the pharmaceutical companies of the
world direct our conceptual development
because I think it's just still
important and especially for young
people that they should know that there
are really deeply deep problems to be
solved deep intellectual problems to be
solved I think such questions for
example of can we compute behavior from
a wiring diagram I don't think we can do
it yet but certainly if we're going to
gain an understanding of
we must accomplish that task there are
many questions like that in the brain
sciences and I think they're looking at
the audience upstairs who should be
getting back to the labs to trance all
these problems because they are the
future of the science so I just would
like to finish here and hope I've just
given you a glimpse i'm sure i just
opened myself to many questions but i
didn't want to take you much time
from Richard axel thank you very much
don't go to the lab just yet it's good
to see the drill sticking around because
so you'll have a chance to ask questions
of our our speakers later dr. axel has
been promoted heavily now so he better
have a heck of a lecture coming up our
next noblest has enjoyed that what you
might call the sweet smell of success by
studying smell itself he's the co-owner
of the 2004 Nobel Prize in medicine or
physiology for clarifying how the
olfactory system works dr. Richard Axel
is a university professor and professor
of biochemistry and molecular biophysics
and okay it's all up there I don't like
that pathology at the Columbia
University College of Physicians and
Surgeons dr. Axel's research continues
to focus on all Factory
perception in particular how the sense
of smell is established during
development how it may change over time
and ultimately how certain smells can
elicit appropriate thoughts and
behaviors please welcome dr. Richard axe
[Applause]
thank you I too want to congratulate MIT
Susumu tonegawa the members of the
pickle for this marvelous institution
the opportunity to celebrate the opening
of this edifice thank you for the
opportunity to be here now as you might
surmise I'm going to talk to you today
about one aspect of neuroscience that
intensely interests me perception this
is not a nose
it is portrayal by the surrealist Rene
Magritte of his own brains
representation of the external world
it's a vignette that reals reveals a
tension between image and reality a
sense of slippage that is a source of
creativity that's persistent in aught
brought to its culmination by the
Surrealists the problem as to how the
brain represents the external world of
course is not only a central theme in
art but is at the very core of
philosophy psychology and neuroscience
it is the very essence of the problem of
perception and this is what I want to
talk with you about this morning
now let's first consider the first
problem in perception and that is the
recognition of sensory stimuli there are
many ways for organisms to probe the
external world some smell it others
listen to it many see it each species
therefore lives in its own unique
sensory world to which other species may
be partially or even totally unaware a
whole series of specific devices alien
to you
perception have emerged bio sonar in
bats infrared detectors and snakes
sensitivity to magnetic fields in birds
so what this means is that what an
organism detects in its environment is
only part of what is around it and that
part differs in different organisms to
me this means the brain functions not by
recording an exact and precise image of
the world but by creating its own
selective picture a picture that's
largely determined by what is important
for the survival and reproduction of the
species by inference then sensory
impressions are apprehended through the
lens of a particular perceiving brain
and the brain must therefore be endowed
with an a priori potential to recognize
the sensory world our perceptions are
not direct recordings of the world
around us rather they're constructed
internally according to a set of innate
rules colors tones tastes smells do not
exist as such outside of the brain
biological reality I would argue
therefore reflects the particular
representation of the external world
that a brain is able to build and a
brain builds with genes where therefore
trapped in the representation of the
world made possible by our genes and
can't conceive of realizing it in any
other way but how can genes provide
insight into the astonishing problem the
problem of how the brain represents this
world the brain consists solely of a
collection of excitable neurons how is
it that the rich array of mechanical
optical chemical properties that define
touch hearing vision smell taste can be
represented by bits of electrical
activity
that can only vary in two parameters
time and space I'd like to illustrate
this problem by discussing how the
chemosensory world is represented in the
brain how chemical structures can be
represented in brain space we will move
through this
I hope either quickly let's consider the
problem in the context of what Sidney
has alluded to that is microcircuitry
the olfactory system is quite simple you
smell by virtue of an epithelium a
collection of sensory neurons that
reside in the posterior recesses of your
nose the epithelium consists of a neural
a sensory neuron which sends a process
out to the external world and it is on
the very tips of this process that
reside the receptors that bind odors and
translate the energy of odor binding
into alterations in the electrical
properties of the membrane and this is
then transmitted down an axon into the
brain and this axon actually passes
directly through the skull so we have a
direct connection in this system between
the outside world
and the brain we can divide the problem
of how it is that we can smell as
reductionists into two problems first
then how is it that we can recognize
this universe of molecular structures
that we call odors man for instance is
thought to be able to recognize hundreds
of thousands of discreet odors I have no
idea where this number comes from but
nonetheless this is a serious problem
but a more complex problem is the
problem of how we discriminate this vast
array of odors that is how does the
brain know
what the nose is smelling now the first
problem was solved by the efforts of
Linda buck in the laboratory about 15
years ago when Linda isolated the genes
encoding the receptors that sit on the
tips of these neurons that recognize
odors and what she observed is that
unlike vision in which three
photoreceptor molecules are capable of
recognizing wavelengths of light that
accommodate color vision and only 30
receptors are required for taste in
humans 900 receptors perhaps 3 to 5
percent of our chromosome is dedicated
to the recognition of odors and this
concept this principle of a vast array
of moleculus of receptors threads
through all of you care eukaryotic
species so we recognize the vast array
of straw of molecular structures the
vast number of odors by virtue of
maintaining in our genomes a very large
number of odorant receptor genes
now these odorant receptor genes allow
us to pose the second problem that is
how does the brain know what the nose is
smelling in molecular in molecular terms
we can now ask then how does the brain
know which of the multiple receptors
have been activated by a given odor if I
can come up with a cogent model for this
I have the beginnings of an
understanding of perceptual
discrimination this was simplified for
us by the observation that of given
neuron in the nose makes only one
receptor and so we could now reduce the
problem of how does the brain know which
of the multiple receptors were active by
asking which how does the brain know
which
ron's have been activated and by analogy
with other sensory systems we could then
ask does the brain know which neurons
are activated by segregating the
positions of those neurons in brain
space now we've known for over a century
that each of the sensory modalities that
is vision touch taste smell and hearing
indeed are segregated in cortical space
as you see here but not only are these
modalities segregated in cortical space
that the individual Regis sensory
regions of the brain are subdivided
further such that the position of
electrical activity in a given region
provides information about the position
of a stimulus in space and about the
quality of a stimulus if you allow me to
return to the bat for example and you
look at the auditory the Hearing Centers
of the bat brain what you observe is
that one important component of an
auditory stimulus of a sound is of
course frequency and difference
frequencies activate neurons along an
axis of the auditory center of the bat
brain so that the quality of sound is
determined by the position of neural
stimulation along this axis you also
will notice interestingly that this
frequency map in the brain is not
proportionate there is a huge area of
the brain that is tuned to frequencies
which are surround about 60 kilohertz
and it's that particular frequency that
is the frequency of the echo that the
bat uses for its bio so know
our ability so the brain this
disproportion occurs to meet the unique
evolutionary requirements of the
individual organisms allows an organism
to evolve within an ecologic niche to
accommodate its particular needs and
those particular needs differ in
different organisms
now what about smell indeed very quickly
a series of genetic studies initiated by
Peterman bartson Fung Wah in the
laboratory told us that indeed there is
a spatial map in factory centers in the
brain we could genetically alter mice so
that neurons that make one of the
thousand receptors were blue and we
could follow those axons as they course
back into the brain and we observe that
all the neurons that make receptor a all
converge on a fixed point in the brain
and that point differs from the neurons
that make receptor B moreover this map
is relatively constant in all
individuals in a species so there is a
spatial map and the identification of an
anatomic map immediately suggests a
model for odor discrimination which says
that different odors will activate
different combinations of receptors
which in turn will activate different
combinations of discrete low Tsai in the
brain so that cherry might activate this
array within the brain and lemon a
second non identical array the quality
of an odor in such a model the quality
of any percept
in such a model would be encoded by
different spatial patterns of activity
in the brain
is the model true can we look at the
function of the brain in response to
different olfactory percepts and do we
see that different odors elicit
different patterns of activity and can
we relate these patterns of activity to
different behaviors to do this we
switched organisms this is a mammal this
is the fruit fly Drosophila the fruit
fly Drosophila not a terribly attractive
visages it does afford some advantages
that is it is an organism that is
genetically facile that exhibits an
array of olfactory driven behaviors that
are mediated by a nervous system that is
a hundred thousand times numerically
simpler than that
of a mammal and so indeed we were able
to address these issues of brain
activity during perception by applying
by first observing that the fly brain
remarkably despite the six hundred
million years of evolution that separate
flies from man exhibit the very same
principles of organization and function
in the peripheral nervous system system
despite the fact that a fly uses an
antenna and we use unknowns many
receptors one receptor preneur on
neurons bearing a given receptor all
project to a fixed point in the brain
this is called the antenna lobe it's
functionally equivalent to our olfactory
bulb so we could in the fly by using
rather sensitive imaging technologies
multiphoton imaging technologies that
Susumu eluded
simply ask the question can we identify
unique patterns of neural activity that
are the signature for different odors
and indeed this is precisely what two
fellows in the lab have done what we're
looking at is the old fact the antennae
lobe of a fly brain in response to the
major component of Apple versus the
major component of banana and we can ask
are they unique signatures what happens
when we give Apple
strange let's look at what happened
strange this is the pattern we see this
is a movie but it's not playing and when
we give banana suffice it to say that
indeed different odors elicit very
different patterns of neural activity
and we can indie and every odor gives a
very different pattern of neural
activity and these patterns are constant
in all individuals in a species so they
form a signature for an odor now we can
relate individual patterns to individual
behaviors one of the most robust
behaviors that a fly exhibits is rather
interesting and evolutionarily
significant and that is when you hurt
flies when you stress flies they they
exude a pheromone and this pheromone
tells other flies to avoid that
environment and they do so robustly one
of the major components in an experiment
with Seymour Benzer and David Anderson
of such an olfactory avoidance cue we
found is carbon dioxide well we give
carbon dioxide to a fly and image its
brain what we see is he had a different
pattern of activity so indeed different
odors elicit different patterns of
activity and we can demonstrate that
this pattern of activity is responsible
for avoidance behavior for a food
genetically silenced this locust or the
neurons that go into this locust or the
neurons that come out of this locust we
can eliminate avoidance behavior
so what I've shown you is that different
odors indeed elicit different patterns
of activity and that different patterns
of activity can be related to give
specific behaviors I can with accuracy
look down on this pattern and discern
what the fly has encountered in nature
but I've accomplished this and now you
have accomplished this with your eyes
how does the fly do it how does the fly
know that this pattern is Apple and this
pattern is the banana the fly brain does
not have eyes to look down on this
patcher
how then does the fly reconstruct this
deconstructed image of an apple this is
a simple form of an important and
elusive problem it's called the binding
problem how bits of electrical activity
are bound into a meaningful percept
inherent in the binding problem is yet
another problem the parsing problem that
is if I mix apple and banana I will
generate a new pattern of five low sigh
of activity yet I can distinguish apple
and banana within this mix how is it
that an organism's brain can parse out
of this set of discrete low sigh the
individual units that constitute apple
and banana the binding problem is one
that is shared by all sensory systems
elegant work by you will and we so by
Sameer Zeki have shown that to obtain
knowledge of what it is seeing the
visual brain for example does not merely
passively represent image
that are reflected on the retina rather
the brain must actively deconstruct and
then reconstruct the visual world a
visual image is deconstructed first in
the retina and ultimately passes via
parallel processing pathways that report
distinct components of an image and this
is shown schematically here so color is
represented in visual brain in a region
known as v4 whereas cells in v5 are
responsive to the movement of an image
and an adjoining area of v3 is
responsive to form V 3 and V 5 are
independent of the color of the stimulus
and lesions in v4 allow one to see an
image rather well with clarity but only
in shades of gray this segregation
immediately poses a problem in the
reconstruction or binding of a
perceptual image how is a spatial map in
the brain such that I've described to
you
red power bits of electrical activity
integrated to allow for meaningful
recognition of the quality and nature of
a sensory image I've already argued that
sensory input the bottom-up process is
incomplete it results in an incomplete
and selective image of physical reality
that differs in different individuals
the image is completed by the brain by a
top-down process that brings experience
expectation emotion to the binding
process to how you view an image if this
is true then perception as originally
suggested by Richard Gregory is only a
hypothesis a best guess that never truly
approaches reality our assumptions are
based in part on
input and impart from the brain stored
record a record that is nourished by
sensory experience let's consider the
problem of binding that Salvador Dali
poses for us in the slave market with
the bust of Voltaire now the visual in
information that enters Europe is
entering our eyes is the same for
everyone in the room but some of you
will immediately recognize the bust of
Voltaire whereas others will only see
two women two nuns we are binding the
very same sensory stimuli in different
ways once having seen this image however
on second view binding will be
instantaneous experience shapes the way
you integrate incoming sensory
information
now if perception really is just an
assumption of best guess then you can
get it wrong this triangle for example
provides a classic example of illusory
binding I don't know whether you can see
it in this led do you see a triangle
this is an image composed simply of
three Packman but this is not at all
what you are focusing on you see a
triangle with equilateral sides that are
quite clear but these sides do not exist
your brain is trying to use its
preconceived notion of the big visual
world to make what is not and this is an
illusion consider a second example what
you see is our president mr. Bush along
with our vice president mr. Cheney
right
roll what you see is our president mr.
Bush and his face is inserted into the
face of mr. Cheney you are looking
unfortunately as at 2:00 mr. Bush's look
at the nose the nose the mouth the eyes
this is not Cheney at all this is Bush
this is an illusion you are seeing
according you are taking the information
that is going in and adding to it
expectation and creating a top-down
bottom-up binding which is wrong
finally if perception is indeed a
hypothesis it can be challenged and that
is precisely what Rene Magritte did
Magritte defines common sense the common
sense of our brain deliberately and with
great success in this painting caught
Blanc it is confounding it goes against
everything the brain has ever seen
learned and stored in its memory we can
have no preconceived notion here because
the brain cannot represent this bizarre
scene it is an act of the imagination
and it fascinates precisely because our
brains cannot find a solution it is a
classic example of non-binding so let me
very quickly return to the biology of
the binding problem how is this
deconstructed olfactory map
reconstructed one disturbingly seductive
model argues that the combinatorial of
signals that we've observed in this part
of the olfactory system as highly
insular segregated neural signals might
come together and report to a locus in
higher olfactory centers which would
then provide us with a refined olfactory
image
the notion of a Jasmine cell in
olfaction analogous to a grandmother
cell envisioned we've tried to look at
this in our laboratory and ask all these
spatial maps reflected in higher
olfactory centers so here you see the
map in the antenna low neurons
expressing a receptor go into a discreet
insular locus which is segregated from
all other low-side how then do we bring
together the combinatorial of activation
what we observe is that in high brain in
the olfactory cortex there is also a map
it is invariant in all individuals and
different 'lose I report to different
low sigh in high olfactory centers but
the character of the map is different
the map is dispersed it is inter
digitated and it is integrative so it
affords the opportunity for integration
suggesting the possibility that indeed
this olfactory center is integrating
reading the combinatorial of spatial
information again in a spatially defined
way now let me summarize then by arguing
that the elucidation of an olfactory map
both in the olfactory bulb the antennae
lobe or the analogous visual centers
brings us closer to an understanding but
it still leaves us with a profound and
basic problem in perception for no
matter how high in the fly brain we map
a sensory circuit we must still ask who
in the brain is looking down on the
this image on this spatial pattern
though we may look at these odor of
vocht images with our brains and
recognize a spatial pattern is unique
and we can even readily associate them
with particular stimuli but the brain I
repeat does not have eyes who reads the
map
how are the spatially bits of spatially
defined bits of information in the
visual system the olfactory system
decoded to allow for the perception of
an image so we're left with an old
problem
the problem of the ghost in the machine
and I leave this task to the
Ghostbusters the neuro scientists of the
pic our Center Earl Miller Matt Wilson
and Susumu tonegawa thank you